qu'est-ce que tu penses de la position
de la France insoumise Yassine Jean-Luc
Mélenchon alors euh moi j'aimerais
vraiment qu'on puisse distinguer la
France insoumise de Jean-Luc Mélenchon
il y a pas que lui hein euh il y a pas
que lui mais souvent on dit la France
insoumise euh bon moi j'ai ma position
sur Mélenchon elle est connue moi je
connais même pas son emploi c'est-àdire
que déjà je pense qu'on est du niveau
Rael il se réveille le matin il met un
pantalon en l'in et dit aux gens vous
pensez ça juste je vous parle les amis
de quelqu'un qui n'a pas de mandat oui
mais Mathilde Panau mathil Panau Louis
Boyard oui ouiar était à notre place il
y a pas si longtemps ouais Mélanchon a
fait une faute politique inadmissible et
je le dis à ce tu sais moi je suis
profondément attaché à la politique de
ce pays 70 % des musulmans voté
Mélenchon comment il les a remercié
juste après ils ont créé la nuupess ils
ont écarté tous les Arabes et les Noirs
tête de liste pour mettre des bobos
magnifiques qui t'expliquent qui
t'expliqu qu'ils connaissent mieux les
quartiers no cause et compagnie je tiens
à le rappeler sur un plateau quand même
important que Jean-Luc Mélenchon n'est
pas le Tutur légal des musulmans en
France c'est pas un berger et les
musulmans ils le suivent les musulmans
c'est pas un bloc homogène il y a des
gens de droite des gens de gauche et
ceux qui ont fait le choix de Jean-Luc
Mélenchon sous prétexte parce qu'il les
défendait et ben dorén avant ils sont
dans sa paume et les gens qui créent un
lien avec lui se retrouve dans une
position fortement désagréable ce qu'a
fait Mélenchon dorénavant moi je vous
entendais parler de calcul politique et
compagnie je suis les amis il y a un an
seulement que le Président il est en
place si on est à ce rythme là je vous
annonce on va on va exploser en plein
vol Jean-Luc Mélenchon a promis la
fureur le problème c'est que chaque
débat en France dans lequel il rentre
finit par imploser on oublie même le
débat donc moi ce que je dis je suis pas
un représentant des musulmans mais je me
représente moi-même c'est déjà pas mal
les musulmans déjà je vais te dire ils
ont une ascension économique que les
Juifs ont connu c'est-à-dire que les
juifs et les musulmans grandissaient
dans les mêmes quartiers et je te prends
une ville qui est connue ça harcelle et
les gens commencent à quitter sarcell
ils ont une réussite économique c'est ce
qui est r TR de toucher la communauté
musulmane où des gens commencent à
acheter des des maisons commence à avoir
une ascension économique il se retrouve
pas dans le discours de Mélenchon si ce
n'est que quand il prend une position
sur soi-disant l'islamophobie là il
vient de montrer quelque chose que je
n'admets pas et c'est pour ça que je le
dis au musulmans ce n'est pas un ami un
ami qui parle à ta place pour te mettre
dans la merde c'est pas un ami et
aujourd'hui on parle pas d'elle mais
celle qui récolte c'est celle qui va
nous diviser en 2027 les amis elle
s'appelle Marine Le Pen pardon de vous
dire ça mais je le dis à la communauté
juive au rassemblement de l'indice qui
m'a fait plaisir c'est qu'ils ont dit
non à Jean Messi ils ont dit non à ERC
Zemour mais quand des des élus de
l'extrême droite viennent défiler avec
la communauté juive mais les amis moi
mon grand-père il a mis personne dans un
train mon grand-père c'était un
tirailleur marocain comme beaucoup de
gens de quartier et il a combattu les
nazis c'est pas pour en retrouver dans
sa famille et aujourd'hui on nous met on
nous ferait croire que nous soi-disant
on n pas d'histoire on n pas de vécu et
mélanchau aujourd'hui il passe à côté de
cette histoire parce que moi mon
grand-père il a pas fait ça pour
l'oseille je vous le dis il a fallu
qu'un film sorte en France pour que un
moment on reconnaisse le statut des
tirailleurs c'est nos grands-parents qui
étaient dans le front et qui butai des
nazis et là aujourd'hui Jean-Luc
Mélenchon c'est ce que je lui dis faut
qu'il arrête de faire d'une concession
privée les musulmans parce que les
conséquences elles sont tragiques et je
le dis pour ceux que ça inquiète ne
croyez pas que tous les matins on se
réveille et c'est le grand moufti de la
France et là d'ailleurs c'est ce qu'il
est en train de faire il est en train de
reculer sur sa position parce qu'il est
en train de dire il a eu un malentendu
pas
reculé il a reculé puis il est reparti
donc VO mais parce que cy la vérité
c'est que Jean-Luc mélanchot aujourd'hui
dans son parti il y a des gens de talent
je vous le redis les
amis
dis en a d'autresel garido sont des gens
même si on est opposé gar d'ailleurs
voilà avec qui je m'entends bien était
elle mérite mieux il
fautut al mérite
mier C à quelques semaines près si cet
homme avait démissionné si jeanluc
mélanch était sorti de l'élection il y a
1 an 10 ans qui nous avait dit faites
mieux je te jure que tous autour de la
table nous aurions reconnu à cet homme
politique un grand talent il est en
train de s'umilier de jour en jour de
semaine en semaine en faisant croire que
ce pays aujourd'hui serait clivé en deux
il y a les pros et il y a les nantis et
je te jure j'ai vu toutes ces sorties
depuis une semaine je ne sais même pas
où est-ce qu'il veut en venir alors
autant moi et aujourd'hui et et quand tu
parlais aujourd'hui de dire mais
pourquoi tu prends pas position guedos P
à son homme disait quelque chose de très
intéressant quand je l'avais croisé il
disait un humoriste est toujours dans
l'opposition il a pas d'allé un
humoriste un humoriste il monte sur
scène il tape sur tout le monde un
humoriste il est jamais il est jamais
dans l'opposition cont terrorisme mais
juste je te dis mais moi je te dis
quelque chose un humoriste n'est jamais
opposé dans l'opposition en disant je
suis pour le terrorisme un humoriste il
se positionne toujours contre le
terrorisme bien sûr mais juste pour
finir là-dessus et et te dire quelque
chose tu sais quand tu t'engages tes pas
invité au soirées et je le dis aux
artistes qui veulent pas s'engager moi
je préfère marcher la tête haute dans la
rue que tête baissée dans les soirées du
showbiz moi je préfère qu'un chauffeur
livir un taxi m'arrête en disant je suis
un mec formidable que de voir
aujourd'hui mais pardon hier vous avez
pas cité un nom Pierre n il s'est engagé
Géraldine non j'ai cité Jean du jardin
par ex d'accord CIT Kilian Mbappé et par
que je
dis les amis c'est pas ça c'est que un
moment les gens sont complexes tous les
gens des quartier ne se ramène pas à
quelqu'un qui leur ressemble forcément
et moi ce que j'aurais voulu
objectivement c'est que comprennent
autour de cette table que les artistes
qui s'engagent c'est ceux qui rentrent
dans l'histoire n'est pas Mohamed Ali
qui veut alors donc donc donc donc tu tu
tu tu tu comprends pas qu'il ne s'engage
pas les grands artistes et les grands
footballleurs les mais attends moi je te
dis quelque chose moi je suis fan de
Coluche je suis fan de je te dis
n'importe je suis fan de Coluche voilà
prenons Coluche c'est la mort rend
iconique il MEUR en accident de moto on
parle des Restos du cœur ceux qui aiment
la culture française se souviennent que
Coluche les dernières années de sa vie
était black listé personne ne voulait de
lui et vu que la mort ça trend iconique
il y a un espèce de romantisme et ben du
coup aujourd'hui on parle ah si coluch
était là si coluch était là et ben mon
cul oui mais pourquoi on Marci parle du
batlan il parle de tous les attentats
pourquoi pas l'attentat en Israël le
problème c'est les Juifs c'est qui
problme dit le problème c'est les Juifs
Omar
aujourd'huioup pourquoi ça pose un
problème pourquoi le Batan ça par nous
reste on va accir fr tapir et Karine zbi
alors c'est quoi ta réponse làus non
mais je suis pas auar mais juste dire
quelque chose Gérald ça m' fait rire
parce que tu as dit c'est quoi le
problème c'est les Juifs je te jure par
sympathie on ne peut pas non non les
amis les amis ça c'est pas des
accusations c'est pas une phrase qui
sort en l'air Omar n'a pas de problème
ça je veux bien mettre ma main coupée
c'est juste un moment regarde ça viendra
quand ça viendra et même j'ai envie de
te dire mieux vaut tard que jamais il y
a plein d'humoristes aujourd'hui moi
j'aimerais faire carrière aux États-Unis
parce que m'engager bah j'aurais eu
j'aurais eu des retomb bon politique ça
viendra quand ça viendra fallit la
sortir C mais fr je vais même te dire
quand est-ce que ça viendra ça pas dans
ton émission je vous le dis ça sera sur
7 à 8 tu auras une musique elle va lui
dire omomar je vous sens affecté et
omomar il va dire j'ai pris le temps de
réfléchir je vous les donne moi les
séquences télé ou sinon les amis c'est
parce qu'il pas venu
là réfléchir pour dire que tu es ému
parce qu'il y a des gens qui on été
tu le cur la réflexion il y a un an j'ai
failli me faire tabasser sur ce plateau
je reviens ici avec émotion pour vous
dire déjà quelque chose les amis nous
sommes français on est on a un devoir
d'exemplarité j'en ai assez de venir
vous justifier l'idée que dans mon
mantra de français quand l'équipe de
France gagne je pleure quand l'équipe du
Maroc gagne aussi bon ils m'ont rattrapé
je pleure aussi mais ce que j'ai envie
de vous dire c'est que la société c'est
pas Twitter c'est pas binaire il y a des
gens qui sont touchés dans leur chair et
je veux le dire à la communauté juive il
y a 381 juifs francoisraéliens qui vont
débarquer là si je aller à l'aéroport
pour les accueillir je le ferai mais
n'oubliez pas c'est pas parce qu'on vous
dit pas ce qu'on fait qu'on ne fait pas
c'est juste ça la vérité merci merci
merci merci Daniel merci parce qu'elle
voulait parler elle parlera sur l'autre
sujet